hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and now that we
know that joyboy has returned in the
form of monkey d luffy everyone's been
wondering what exactly do we mean when
we say that luffy is joy boy is joy boy
an essence or a consciousness that is
present within luffy or is he an essence
or consciousness that is present within
the nika devil fruit or was he maybe the
original user of the nika devil fruit
800 years ago
did luffy inherit joyboy's will whatever
that means or does luffy just embody
joyboy's ideals of freedom and equality
or is something else going on here in
this video i will argue that what we
know as joy boy may actually be one of
the notorious ancient weapons and that
luffy may now be the physical embodiment
of that weapon just like shirahoshi is
the physical embodiment of the ancient
weapon poseidon you guys know the drill
if you enjoy our one piece videos and
you want us to keep it going just leave
a quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it really helps with that
youtube algorithm and remember that
subscribing and hitting that bell is a
completely free but very real way of
directly supporting the channel before
we get into it thank you to friends and
dragons for sponsoring this video
friends and dragons is a free to play
strategy based mobile game that is
available on the app store and google
play it is a unique combo of hero
collection strategy and puzzler with a
rich fantasy world setting what makes
this game stand out from others is its
unique co-op play and its special
controls that allow you to pick one hero
and then use him to quickly move the
rest of the team around the battlefield
it is a really cool way of interacting
with your heroes instead of having to
move every single one of them one by one
and this unlocks some really interesting
strategies in a ton of different
gameplay options the key to crushing it
in this game is to collect new and
powerful heroes and then to upgrade them
friends and dragons has a diverse cast
of over 150 heroes to collect and once
you collect them you can make them
stronger by equipping items and
upgrading their skills friends and
dragons features loads of special
limited time events and these events
will reward you with awesome prizes it's
fun addicting and rewarding so check it
out right now link in the description
download friends and dragons for free by
clicking the link or scan the qr code on
the screen and get a special bonus of
one free summon daily energy potions and
gold for free and an exclusive offer
available via my link only so don't
delay link in the description finally
this video will contain one piece manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned okay so let's start
this off in a bit of an unconventional
place remember that scene inside the
chamber of flowers in pangea castle when
the mysterious imusamam is looking at
four photographs there is a photo of
luffy blackbeard shirahoshi and vivi the
photos of luffy and blackbeard are
ripped up the photo of shirahoshi is
being stabbed through with a sword and
the photo vivi appears to be still
intact i think this scene is a lot more
important than we even realize and
here's why on the surface it makes
perfect sense for the shadow ruler of
the world government to have photos of
blackbeard and luffy since these two are
famous pirate outlaws who clearly pose a
threat to the world government the
reason for including photos of
shirahoshi and vivi are less obvious
although if imusama is aware that
shirahoshi is poseidon then yeah it's
true that poseidon also poses a major
threat to the world government however
vivi is really the odd one out here i
mean sure she's the princess of a
kingdom but there are like 50 kingdoms
being represented at the reverie so
clearly just being a princess of one
kingdom is not the reason why vivi's
photo was included here the one thing
that vivi and shirahoshi have in common
though is their connection to ancient
weapons shirahoshi is an ancient weapon
poseidon and vivi is the princess of
alabasta where another ancient weapon
called pluton is set to be located
pluton is believed to be somewhere in
alabasta and from what we know so far
pluton appears to be a battleship that
was created in water 7 many centuries
ago according to crocodile pluton has
the ability to completely destroy an
entire island with a single blast and
while there's been a lot of speculation
about whether pluton is really a
physical battleship or whether it is
actually something more similar to
poseidon it does appear that pluton is
at least in part a physical ship we know
this because the blueprints for building
it do exist and although we don't see
them in detail we are led to believe
that these blueprints are real on one
occasion frankie shows the blueprints to
luchi and kaku who are both skilled
shipbuilders and they appear to
recognize them as real but if pluton is
just a physical battleship than anyone
can use then why would emu single out
vivi the answer might lie in the complex
history of the nefertari royal family
the nefertari family were one of the 20
royal families who came together to
create the world government 800 years
ago however unlike the other royal
families the nefertari refused to leave
alabasta in order to live as celestial
dragons in marijua
now this might seem like the nefertari
just had a personal preference for
staying in their homeland but the choice
that they made is far bigger and more
consequential than that the other royal
families see the nefertari family as
traders for refusing to relocate to
marijuana and this was confirmed during
the reverie arc it's likely that they
would have been seen as traders even 800
years ago and we know how the world
government normally deals with traitors
and yet the nefertari were left alone
and alabasta remained a founding member
of the world government despite their
perceived treachery this is important
because it means that the nefertari must
have had some sort of insurance policy
that prevented the world government from
punishing them for their decision don't
forget that even harming one celestial
dragon could be enough for the world
government to destroy an entire kingdom
and yet alabasta was seemingly not
punished for betraying the very concept
of the celestial dragons furthermore the
fact that the nefertari family has been
concealing a poneglyph from the world
government again suggests that their
relationship with the other royal
families was not as friendly as we might
think i think that the reason why the
nefertari were able to defy the other
royal families and get away with it was
the fact that they were in possession of
pluton and that they could use it
against the world government if they
ever decided to attack alabasta that at
least was the case at the beginning
although it seems that the knowledge of
where exactly pluton is and how to use
it was lost over time
however if imusama is still interested
in vivi after all this time then vivi as
the current princess of alabasta and the
heir to the nefertari family must have
some sort of direct connection to pluton
a connection that probably she doesn't
even know about even though pluton
appears to be just a really powerful
man-made warship it is possible that not
just anyone can use it even if they
could find it what if the nefertari
royal bloodline holds the key to
actually using pluton just like
shirahoshi holds the key to using
poseidon if that were the case and if
vivi was actually instrumental in
activating pluton then imusama taking a
special interest in vivi makes perfect
sense and from everything we know so far
about the mysterious events that
ultimately occurred at the reverie it is
clear that the nefertari family and
alabasta have been profoundly affected
after that scene with emu and the photos
we are led to believe that a death
occurred at the reverie as well as an
attempted murder we don't get to see
what exactly happened but we do get to
see the reactions of many people as they
react to the news being reported by the
world economy newspaper by the way this
is news that the world government tried
to hush up but big news morgan's decided
to report it anyway the news is clearly
about sabo at least in part and the
revolutionaries are both saddened and
shocked to learn what happened inside
the goa kingdom the king and queen are
in disbelief and both makino and adan
are in tears the implication is clearly
that sabo may have died off-screen
but this doesn't make much sense why
would oda go through all that trouble of
bringing sabo back and having him
consume ace's devil fruit only to then
kill him off scream i mean that would be
insane it is important to mention that
in the anime in particular this big news
is shown to be especially tragic for the
people of alabasta who are clearly
distraught and in mourning this implies
that whatever happened at the reverie
clearly involves the nefertari royal
family something either happened to king
cobra or princess vivi or both
this suggests that after that scene with
the photos imusama may have made a move
against the nefertaris possibly because
of their connection to pluton if i had
to guess i'd say that cobra may have
been killed and vivi may have been the
victim of an assassination attempt but
she was rescued by the revolutionaries
sabo may then have been falsely accused
of killing cobra and kidnapping vivi but
if that were the case then the alabaster
reaction would make sense but the
reactions of the revolutionaries and
makino and the don don't really fit i
don't think they would be so shocked and
saddened if sabo had made a clean
getaway even if he was being framed for
a terrible crime the only way their
reaction makes sense is if sabo really
did die or if he was actually captured
and arrested for these alleged crimes
and is about to be executed if that
second part is true then it seems way
too similar to what happened to ace but
at the same time this would be a
surefire way to lure luffy into a trap
and force a showdown between him and the
world government so we'll have to wait
and see either way i'm willing to bet
that both sabo and vivi are alive and
that they wouldn't be killed off screen
as far as cobra goes though he was
probably the one who was killed and if
he was killed because of the nefertari
connection to pluton then we have to go
back to those four photos if shirahoshi
is poseidon and vivi is pluton or at
least connected to it in some
fundamental way then could luffy and
blackbeard also be connected to ancient
weapons
the third weapon that we know about is
uranus although its name is literally
the only thing that we know about it and
yes i know that in english uranus is
also pronounced as uranus but since i'd
rather not keep saying that over and
over again i'll just use uranus oh when
people start complaining about this in
the comments then i'll pull a real chat
move and just start using the ancient
greek pronunciation from now on uranos
anyway we know that all three ancient
weapons bear the names of greek gods
poseidon the greek god of the sea storms
earthquakes and horses pluton the greek
god of the earth land and the underworld
and uranus a primordial god who is the
personification of the sky and the
father of the titans i often see people
saying that pluton actually comes from
the roman god pluto but no the word
pluton originates in greek mythology
where it was used as another name for
hades the roman pluto actually comes
from the greek pluton according to robin
even in the world of one piece all three
weapons were named after a god but since
this is a world that is different from
our own these gods may also be different
from the gods we know from ancient
greece that said the uranus from greek
mythology is currently our best hint for
what this ancient weapon might actually
be clearly it is associated with the sky
and the heavens and sky-related things
like rain and wind but what if uranus is
also associated with another celestial
god in the world of one piece the sun
god nika sun god nika is a mythical
warrior who was worshiped by slaves as a
sun deity since ancient times the slaves
prayed that sun god nika would one day
come and liberate them it was later
revealed that there is a mythical zoned
devil fruit called the hitohitomi model
nika which is of course the true name of
luffy's devil fruit the gorosei were
aware of this devil fruit's existence
and the world government has been trying
to capture it for centuries but they
never succeeded it was as if this devil
fruit had a will of its own and like it
was actively running away from the world
government
now it seems that the gorosei didn't
think that the nika fruit was an
immediate threat because it hadn't
awakened in over 800 years the last time
this fruit was fully awakened was all
the way back during the void century and
so the gorosei assumed that as long as
the nika fruit isn't awakened they would
be safe
however the gorosei eventually changed
their approach and they ordered luffy's
immediate execution at the end of
chapter 1043
luffy seemingly dies but he is brought
back to life as his devil fruit awakens
in that moment zunesha proclaims that
joy boy himself
has returned after his devil fruit
awakening luffy unlocks an absolutely
ridiculous new power that allows him to
basically turn reality into toon world
and his power at this point can
definitely be compared with the power of
a god
now the fact that the nika fruit hadn't
awoken since the void century reminded
me a lot of poseidon the ancient weapon
which awakens within a person the
mermaid princess but not every mermaid
princess poseidon only awakens once in
several centuries and the same appears
to be the case for joy boy and the nica
devil fruit and of course pluton hasn't
been seen since the void century either
meaning that just like shirahoshi and
joyboy pluton may be a power that must
be first awakened before it is used and
this is only possible once in several
centuries so what if joyboy is the
ancient weapon uranus and it is only
awakened when multiple specific
conditions are met one of these
conditions is that poseidon must also be
awakened and perhaps pluton as well but
we just don't know that yet another
condition is that the right person must
be in possession of the mythical nika
devil fruit so if the wrong person has
the fruit it will just be the gomu no me
it will not awaken just like it didn't
for 800 years there might even be some
connection to the d-clan
maybe the nika devil fruit must be in
possession of a member of the d-clan in
order to awaken and if it isn't then it
simply won't work just like poseidon
only awakens within members of the
ryugyu royal family and just like pluton
is likely connected to the nefertari
royal family uranus could be connected
to the d-clan this would explain why the
d-clan are considered to be the natural
enemies of the celestial dragons
technically anyone from this clan could
activate uranus under the right
circumstances and if uranus poseidon and
pluton are all activated at the same
time they would likely have the power to
destroy the world government and
overthrow the celestial dragons and this
would certainly explain why the gorosei
suddenly decided that luffy must be
killed at all costs he had to be killed
before his devil fruit awakened and joy
boy aka uranus was activated and if
joyboy really is the ancient weapon
uranus it would lend further credence to
the theory that the artificial devil
fruits known as smiles were an attempt
to recreate the nica mythical zone devil
fruit which is of course a key
ingredient in activating the joyboy
ancient weapon after all 90 of those who
consume a smile devil fruit end up as
failures not only will they not receive
any special power from the fruit but
they will be condemned to laugh
uncontrollably for the rest of their
lives knowing how joy and laughter is
associated with the nika devil fruit
it's almost like these failures become
dark and inverted versions of the true
joy boy so is this the missing piece
are joy boy and son god nika synonymous
with the third ancient weapon uranus if
this were the case then three of the
photos that imusama had in her
possession were related to ancient
weapons shirahoshi is poseidon vivi is
pluton or she is the only one who can
activate it due to her royal bloodline
and luffy is uranus but then what about
the fourth photo blackbeard one argument
could be that maybe uranus once
activated has an effect on every single
d-clan member not just luffy so maybe
they will all become stronger now
including blackbeard but if that was the
explanation then surely dragons in lost
photos would have been there as well i
think that the reason why blackbeard's
photo was included is directly related
to rox d zepic and god valley the god
valley incident was a major event that
took place 38 years ago and the truth
about what happened was strictly hushed
up by the world government today only
the older generations of marines are
even aware of this incident rox d zebek
who is considered to be perhaps the
greatest rival of goal d roger had
assembled an incredibly powerful pirate
crew that consisted of a young
whitebeard kaido and big mom among other
heavy hitters together with this crew
zebek declared war against the world
government and he set out to make
himself the king of the world which
means that he was determined to straight
up overthrow the celestial dragons the
rocks pirates were infamous and fearsome
and they were clearly a massive threat
to global stability one day 38 years ago
zebek and his crew attacked a remote
island known as god valley in chapter
957
sengoku gives us a quick overview of
what happened and it seems that at the
time of zebec's attack multiple
celestial dragons were present on the
island of god valley sengoku doesn't
specify how many celestial dragons were
present or which ones were actually
there we just know that some of them
were on the island along with their
slaves
it is possible that these were
high-ranking world nobles such as the
gorosei because in order to defeat zebek
and to protect the celestial dragons the
world government resorted to an
unprecedented act they agreed to work
together with gold d roger in order to
take zebic down garp and roger did the
heavy lifting in this fight and after
zebek was defeated the rox pirates were
dissolved the truth about this entire
incident was then heavily censored by
the world government and the island of
god valley itself vanished from the face
of the earth we don't know how or why it
vanished but now it is gone and it
cannot even be found on any map by the
way it's important to state that this
wasn't an instance of the world
government calling in a buster call to
blow up everything on the island in
sengoku's own words the island wasn't
blown up with a buster call the island
disappeared entirely this is creepy but
also intriguing okay so knowing what we
know about the god valley incident what
is the missing piece here what were
high-ranking celestial dragons doing on
some remote island in the middle of
nowhere these people never seem to stray
far from their holy land unless
something drastic occurs so what drove
them to visit god valley furthermore why
would zebec attack this one island
rather than taking the fight to marijua
itself i mean even if he took down a few
celestial dragons on this island the
battle to overthrow the world government
would be far from over finally why would
garp and goldie roger risk their lives
to protect a bunch of celestial dragons
from zebek i mean even if we say that
garp did it because he was obligated to
do so by his position
roger certainly had no obligation to
protect the world nobles in my opinion
all of this only makes sense if we
insert a missing piece that ties it all
together
a secret weapon of incredible power
perhaps even one of the ancient weapons
themselves the celestial dragons may
have gone to god valley to either locate
or test a game-changing overpowered
weapon since that is something that they
definitely wouldn't do anywhere near
their holy land zebek may have attacked
because he wanted to steal this weapon
and use it to bring down the world
government and become king of the world
roger and garp decided that allowing
zebek to steal the weapon was just too
dangerous so they teamed up to stop him
not because they wanted to protect the
celestial dragons but because they
wanted to protect the rest of the world
from zebek the world government covered
everything up not only because they
didn't want the world to know that roger
helped them but also because they didn't
want anyone to find out about this
ultimate weapon in fact they may have
even used the weapon to wipe god valley
out of existence oh and back when
doflamingo said that he knows about the
hidden treasure of marijuana he may have
been referring to this very weapon so
the reason why blackbeard's photo
appears alongside the photos of
shirahoshi vivi and luffy could be
because he found out about this top
secret weapon and is trying to retrieve
it or maybe he managed to retrieve it
already and that is why his devil fruit
is so unique and why he can use more
than one devil fruit at the same time
the yami yami no me may itself be this
secret weapon and just like the nika
fruit its true name and true nature may
be something completely different from
what we initially thought we actually
have an entire video here on the channel
about the possibility that the yami yami
know me is actually a mythical zone
devil fruit just like luffy's so if you
want to check that out i will link it in
the description at any rate if my theory
about a secret weapon at god valley is
correct then the big question is what
was this weapon was it the yamami itself
was it one of the three known ancient
weapons was it a fourth secret agent
weapon or was it something else
attacking 101 had an interesting theory
about god valley maybe being the
homeland of real dragons the celestial
dragons went there in order to acquire
and train their dragons and zebek tried
to take control of all the dragons in
order to use them to attack marijuana
from the air this is a fascinating
theory although if true i certainly hope
that at least some of the dragons
survived it would kind of suck if we got
an epic god valley flashback only to
learn that yup all those cool dragons
died and we'll never see them again just
a side note subscribing to teching 101
is basically a requirement for every
die-hard one-piece fan and i strongly
recommend it personally i really like
the idea of the four photos that emu was
holding representing four ancient
weapons one of which may be so secret
that hardly anyone even knows about it
if i were to guess what a fourth ancient
weapon might be i would say chaos also
known as the great void that predates
all other existence even the existence
of the gods themselves in greek
mythology chaos is what gave birth to
everything else including darkness
itself so there's a connection to the
yamiyami know me also if anything could
make an entire island just disappear
into the void it would certainly be the
power of chaos
historically chaos has been visually
represented by a variety of symbols
including a sun-like sphere with an eye
hands and feet a serpent or dragon and
various types of spirals chaos could be
directly related to the true nature of
blackbeard's devil fruit and chaos might
be what zebek was looking for at god
valley chaos may also be what blackbeard
is looking for right now or what he has
already found and that is why he caught
the attention of imusama but let me know
what you guys think what is uranus and
could it be something directly related
to joy boy and sun god nika could there
be a fourth ancient weapon out there a
secret ancient weapon that made god
valley disappear into thin air
finally what is the connection between
zebic and blackbeard is blackbeard zebek
sun are they some other type of relation
or does blackbeard's connection to zebek
come down to the fact that they are both
looking for the same thing
chaos don't forget to leave your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you guys enjoyed this video and you want
to see more one piece content here on
the channel just leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
really helps me out with that youtube
algorithm and remember that subscribing
and hitting that bell is a completely
free but very real way of directly
supporting the channel thanks again to
friends and dragons for sponsoring this
video check them out link in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys